qu'est-ce que c'est la fête de Noël
[Rires]
[Musique]
qui traditionnellement ça existe depuis
tant de juger et je sais que tout ce qui
fait la dernièrement c'est une fête
commerciale
et vous croyez musulman
et vous croyez à la la la naissance de
Jésus-Christ bien sûr
vous allez fêter ça en famille ou pas
non les maisons en famille comme ça
c'est-à-dire que on fait des familles
les amis des copains et les copines
pour les catholiques oui et vous vous
sentez concerné oui
pourquoi vous vous sentez concerné
je sens pas mon espace que je suis mon
pays parce que je suis pas entouré par
ma famille et j'ai pas à mon pays oui et
la fête de Noël est une occasion de se
retrouver entre vous oui plus
spécialement que d'autres occasions
comment vous expliquer ça c'est à dire
la fête de Noël
c'est par exemple comme chez nous là une
fête une grande fête religieuse c'est à
dire la naissance
de Mohamed du mec vers Medina et ça j'ai
passé du 22 au 23
et vous savez ce que c'est que la fête
de Noël pour les chrétiens
c'est la fête de naissance de
Jésus-Christ
c'est
une fête
d'accord mais une fois
disons à l'époque et 10 ans de ça
d'accord c'était bon maintenant c'est
fini c'est comme dans toutes les
religions musulmanes c'est pareil
certaines coutumes
j'ai une machine à écrire mais pourquoi
tu as une machine
pour apprendre à lire et à écrire
elle sait même pas où elle est là
[Musique]